MALE SPEAKER: So here
we are at Idealab.
And this is the central section
of Idealab where we
have all the shared services, so
each of these groups here.
We have Human Resources and
Engineering and Design and PR
and Finance.
And each of these are areas that
help the companies get
started and then also focus
on their customer.
Our whole goal is to provide all
of the services that are
more of the heartache functions
of growing a
business, so the company can
focus only on what the needs
are of the customer and build
a product that will satisfy
them the greatest.
And we start the companies right
in one of these pods.
And then, once we decide it's
something that we want to
actually build and incorporate,
we'll move them
over to another part
of the building.
We'll capitalize it with the
first, say, $250,000.
We'll have someone come in as
the beginning or founding CEO
or founding executive.
And then our recruiting
department will help them fill
out the engineering team.
But at the beginning, it will
be using Idealab resources.
So it will be using the Idealab
engineering staff-- we
have programmers on staff--
and borrowing all those
resources to help them get
started as fast as possible.
And gradually, they'll replace
them with their own people.
Eventually, when they grow to
100 people, they move out of
the building.
But I'll take you in a second
to where the companies start
out, where we have room for
a five-person company, a
10-person company, a 20-person
company, a 30-person
company, and so on.
And the facilities department
here moves all the companies
around, so they're always
in the optimal
space for their stage.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: Here, we have
different pods for different
size companies.
And each of these teams are
independent companies.
Now you can see there's no
tall walls or anything
separating one company
from another.
They're all in the same
shared space.
In fact, the whole Idealab
building is 45,000 square
feet, all on one floor,
all very open space.
The whole goal is that there's
the most information sharing
and knowledge transfer from
one company to another.
No two companies are competing
with one another, so there's
no chance of any trade secrets
or anything like that being
misshared between companies.
But this company here, which is
a solar energy company, and
this company here, which is
doing mobile retail loyalty,
they might have nothing in
common, except their VPs of
Marketing might talk together
about strategies for marketing
their companies more
effectively.
Their CEOs might get together
and talk about fund raising.
We would have a lunch for all
of the CTOs across all the
companies in the building,
so they
could share best practices.
We're always bringing in
lecturers to talk to the
companies about best
practices.
Well, the main thing
is they're right
adjacent to one another.
And they're working together
in the same space.
And they're learning about how
to be successful as a company.
Right now, in the building,
we have 12 companies.
When the companies grow
past 100 people, they
have to move out.
And we have 25 companies,
overall, in the whole
portfolio at Idealab
right now.
MALE SPEAKER: 25 companies.